[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Kinsey is
with us in Tacoma Washington hi Kenzie
how are you Hi how are you better than I
deserve how can we
help so okay so I've been my husband and
I have been on your plan off and on but
we are um we've paid off all our debt at
one point and then I was stupid got back
into it um but we're like scorched Earth
you know really really on this plan to
get out of debt and one of the driving
forces is we want to cash flow our kids
college well and this is like the
perfect day listening to all of these um
these kids having or adults having to
pay for college again all their all
their stuff anyways um I have told my
kids I have a 21 19 and a 17y old girls
and I've told them since they were in
middle school we will pay for college
but you have to live at home and you
have to go to a school that we approve
of you have to have good grades but we
will cash flow your school we're not
doing that we have been very transparent
about the struggle we've had with debt
the um the night you know the sleep that
we lost everything like that we I did
the same I did the same thing except to
live at home part why why do you why do
you add that you have to live at home
that um because if
you I don't pay for other people's rent
so there where I live there are so many
colleges within 20 minutes of our home
that there is no reason for you to not
live at home okay so it's your money and
those are your rules what's your
question so my daughter refuses to stay
home and go to school she wants to go to
um a state school but she wants to go to
WSU which is over in Poland which is 6
hours away and they require you to live
on campus and the you have to have the
food program which is about um 2500 to
$4,000 a year so she's opting out hold
on she's op this is very simple she's
opting out of your out of your rules she
opted out yes yes and it's just it's
very difficult for me absolutely and
I've dealt with um my entire career has
been spent sitting with parents and you
drew a hard hard line a very hard line
and very clear line very clear Line This
is the way this is going to be and she
said cool I'm going that way and so the
other side of a very clear very firm
hard line is other people can say well
then I don't want anything to do with
that
boundary and but that doesn't obligate
you to pay no doesn't mean she gets none
of your money right no like I said I
would help with some groceries no no no
no she gets none of your money that's
the rule you set up none of your money
yes no she it out but it's like the it
it kills me when you see your kid
running into it's really is really
heartbreaking to watch people you love
do stupid butt things but you don't get
to vote anymore once they're adults and
the same as if your parents started
spending their money and they were in
their 80s and it's heartbreaking um
because they keep sending money overseas
to somebody who cares about what I mean
or your best friend buys $100,000 worth
of crypto cuz he's an idiot I you can't
stop him
the hardest things is is when you love
somebody they're doing hard things that
are you know are not going to be good
for and so also if she signs up for all
these like all of these loans and things
because she has nothing saved she has
not doing pay she's making a choice do I
have to do I have no you're not liable
you're not liable don't sign anything I
refuse to participate in your Insanity I
love you too much to buy your cocaine
you're an
addict
okay she oped it out she oped it out see
she thinks this the reason we're being
so strong on this I know what she thinks
she thinks you're gonna give her money
anyway and I can't I have two other
girls that she does she think that she
she does think that but like I have to
hold true because my oldest moved out so
we stopped school our middle one is
staying home we're paying for school so
we have to stay true to what we've said
it's unfair to the other two for you to
not have integrity correct zero help now
listen the one thing I have learned and
it is the I think it's the hardest stage
of parenting is being a parent to people
who are grown
up because they're they're allowed to
vote now I can't tell them what to do
anymore I can't use my dad voice it no
longer works I can only use it on the
radio on a listener but I can't use it
on my
kids
but uh that doesn't even work there
actually but uh that you know I can't
use my dad voice anymore not not even
the dog listens to my dad voice anymore
it's just gone I lost my dad voice it
goes you know I have to use persuasion
with everyone now and so my grown kids
get the exact same approach when I
disagree with them that one of my good
friends would
get I either just stand back and watch
and hold my nose or I sit down beside
them and I go you know I love you
and I've got some ideas here of some
dumb things I've done in the past and it
kind of looks like some of the stuff
you're thinking about doing uh would you
like some advice from an older wiser
friend if you say no then I have to shut
up but if you say yes I'll give it to
you and you have to go at it you know
like I've got a friend you know I've Got
Friends my age who have grown kids that
are in their 30s and 40s one of them
called us the other day and said hey uh
we have teenagers you raised three great
kids can we take you to dinner we want
to ask you how to do that so I have to
use the but what I told them was
persuasion I I didn't get to tell them
what to do right they ask and I get to
tell them what I thought and uh but
that's how you get that's how John
persuades me or I persuade John same
thing that's all you can do but you
might want to try that because I got a
feeling in your frustration you've used
your mom voice oh absolutely and your
kids your kids called your kids called
your bluff right yes yeah and i' I've
been working really hard on not talking
at them but talking with them and did
you say this is three girls I have three
girls yes where's Dad in this
conversation so he is he's he backs me
up we're in a different like we're
almost out of our debt and so he's like
he's kind of weighing like okay maybe we
we do this and I said no we have to hold
we have to hold that that's that's what
I meant that's exactly what I meant I
want him to come around front of this
instead of you yeah and I want him to
take his daughter to coffee and say baby
doll I love you and I as as somebody who
loves you not as your dad I think you're
making a mistake here and I want you to
rethink it and I also want to I want to
challenge you on something too not on
this particular one but I'm challenging
the the Bedrock that you've anchored
into one of the greatest gifts a parent
can give their kids sometimes is to say
the words I went about this the wrong
way not not the thing is wrong but I
went about it the wrong way I don't
think this is wise it like I want to
take you to coffee and say hey let me
walk you through why I'm making this
this choice because I'll tell you this
you and everybody's can disagree with me
that's fine but after working in
colleges for 20 years four different
ones across a couple of states and
Consulting in a gajillion more if my
kids decide to go to college one of my
rules is you have to live on campus
Because I want them to experience a
bunch of different people and learn
about how other people do life that's
different that's a different philosophy
but here's the deal your kid is going to
say I'm going to go for this one then so
you set a set of rules great either live
and die by it I but I want you I want
Dad to spend some time talking about why
well I yeah I I actually want mom and
dad to sit down and say do we actually
both believe this okay and then why cuz
it sounds like Mom made a line and Dad's
just going along with it but why but why
stick with it that's right you got to
talk to a teenager you got to talk to a
grown child as a grown sibling a gra
grown child is what it is oxyura as an
equal and talk about why here here's why
I believe this here's why I'm trying to
talk you into it this is the Ramsey Show